Hacksaw Ridge is directed by Mel Gibson
and stars Andrew Garfield and is a true
story of Desmond Ross a man who served
during World War two in the Battle of
Okinawa and he had the unique
requirement of not being able to touch a
gun he didn't want to take a life he
wanted to operate as a medic he wanted
to save lives on the battlefield rather
than take them and this is the true
story of how he met the love of his life
how he tried to convince people that he
wasn't a coward and all the struggles
that come with joining the army and then
saying I don't want to touch a weapon I
had an opportunity to see an early press
screening of this movie and I can tell
you that I left the theater stunned I
drove home in almost complete silence
just thinking about the film that's how
great this film is I am so glad to see
Mel Gibson back directing movies because
ever since the man without a face I
think he's made a lot of really good
movies Braveheart being incredible and
Apocalypto being almost just as good I
love Apocalypto it's so underrated and
with hacksaw bridge I can say that he
has come very close to topping
Braveheart I will say Braveheart is
maybe just ever so slightly on top but
damn it's close what pleased me so much
about this film was how old-fashioned
the filmmaking is this movie feels like
you're watching a film that maybe was
made in the 60s or the 70s just with
better budget and better equipment the
way Gibson moves the camera in this
movie the way he allows entire scenes to
play out just with actors emoting
without speaking the way he allows their
emotion to seep through that frame
Andrew Garfield as Desmond Ross I feel
gives the best performance of his entire
career his accent to me worked very well
I thought he was very very good in the
war scenes which I'll talk about in a
minute but even better in the scenes
with Teresa Palmer who also gives the
performance of her entire career so far
as a nurse that Desmond meets and they
get to know each other and their
relationship was so sweet and so
charming it was like Emma Stone and
Andrew Garfield and the amazing
spider-man except not a shitty movie
also this movie has performances by Sam
Worthington and Luke Bracy
that are really great not since Jai
Courtney being good
in Suicide Squad has something pin so
shocking Vince Vaughn is in this film as
a drill sergeant and is really good I
really bought his performance he has a
lot of really great comedic one-liners
and a lot of good series moments too
he's not just always tearing soldiers
down and saying really insulting things
to their faces a lot of people forget
that he started in more serious movies
like the lost world he still has those
chops and he shows it here but out of
all the supporting cast I got to say
this stand out and I am so happy to say
this Hugo Weaving gives one of the best
performances in this film I haven't seen
him in a movie in a long time I mean
he's really great as all these
characters we love him for like Agent
Smith or V or Elrond or Red Skull all
those characters and big fan favorite
type movies he's a lot of fun but in
this film he gives such a hardened
emotionally powerful performance as
Desmond's father who deals with
alcoholism who was in a war himself
who's very confused about why both of
his sons want to join the war after he's
seen all of his friends die he was so
great in this film and I was so blown
away by his work so let's talk about
those battle sequences because when they
hit they hit I have not seen battle
sequences this disturbing since Saving
Private Ryan now I read a critics review
who said that this film conflicted
itself in regards to its theme that it
has a hero who is against violence and
yet the film is glorifying violence I
personally don't feel that way I think
this film depicted the war scenes almost
like a horror movie
they are terrifying at the press
screening there was a woman sitting in
front of me and there's a moment in the
movie where a character thinks he has
some cover because there's a lot of
smoke and he comes out of the hole that
he's hiding it and then the smoke starts
to dissipate and he goes oh my
cover is going away and you see some of
the enemy coming through the smoke and
the girl sitting in front of me went
like this well the battle scenes in this
movie are frightening and brutally
realistic nothing has been held back
their gory and very well done and
nothing about it seemed Hollywood eyes
or glamorous it was this happened this
sucked here's one guy who tried to do
something
good and that's what was so inspiring
about this movie because around all of
the gunfire around all of the explosions
you had this one slender thin man
running through these lines trying to
save as many people as he could and this
is true this happened this is a real guy
it's so great I'm so used to seeing
these based on a true story movies that
are like these tragic things where as
some idiot did something dumb here's a
great true story movie about a real hero
who did something really awesome
now there's something that some people
were concerned about was that this movie
was going to push Christianity that it
was going to be like you know read the
Bible and everything it's really not
like that
this is more so about one man who had
such strong beliefs and it depicts his
struggle of maintaining them it doesn't
tell you that you should have the same
beliefs it shows a man who has those
beliefs and then shows us how hard it
was for him to maintain them and I think
that's really the focus of the movie and
the whole Christianity aspect kind of
falls by the wayside which is acerra lis
become the focus and that was something
that I appreciated two guys in the end
hacks are rich affected me very deeply
it's one of the best films of the year
one of the best war films I think ever
made and Mel Gibson has proven again
that he is a master behind the camera
but I have but one issue with the movie
and it's almost a nitpick there are
certain character arcs I was wanting to
experience a little bit more from
on-screen and instead we get text
that sort of tells us what happened I
wanted to see certain things happen at
the end and I didn't get to see it's
kind of a nitpick but it's my only real
issue in this movie definitely don't
miss this one guys it is damn great I'm
gonna give hacksaw Ridge and a
guys thank you so much as always for
watching please do check out my fourth
annual Halloween special my wife and I
made we were very hard on it to do a
cool short film involved with our
reviews of cabin in the woods horror
movies it's on my channel right now and
you're going to see a link for that in a
second guys thank you once again you're
the best if you like this you can click
right here and get steppen eyes
[Applause]
[Music]
you